cours est là pour vous entendre sur le
fond de votre accusation parcourt et
julie est votre ami début de l'année
1967 en guadeloupe au début une simple
grève d'ouvriers à la fin un bain de
sang un an plus tard 18 guadeloupéens
sont devant la cour de sûreté de l'état
la principale coupable le gong groupe
d'organisations nationales de guadeloupe
pour moi le comble c'est toute la nôtre
si vous avez des questions à poser
procéder à tous les bois coupé ses 18
guadeloupéens sont jetés en prison et
sont jugées pour atteinte à la sûreté de
l'état
on leur reproche quoi vide c'est pour ça
que cette pièce de ce texte de guy
lafarge que j'ai adapté s'intitule
l'impossible procès mais il nous permet
en fait d'entendre la parole de ces
grands hommes
ils ont pointé du doigt nos inégalités
ça ne concerne pas seulement la
gaudeloupe tous les départements
français d'outre-mer sont concernés et
puis c'est aussi moins un moyen
d'entendre cette parole qui sans doute
tentait de dire à quel point nous avions
soif de justice soif d'égalité
ce matériel des tracts que leurs tirages
à la ronéo je n'ai rien à dire avez vous
participé en guadeloupe à la diffusion
des tracts propagande et un accord des
formations jamais rien si vous me
permettez monsieur le président est
revenu à une pièce événement qui sera
jouée le 19 et le 20 juillet au théâtre
aimé césaire et pour la seconde
représentation des invités très spéciaux
seront dans la salle pour voir leur
histoire se repete cinquante ans plus
tard nos inculpé de l'époque sont ils
encore tous vivants oui pour la plupart
certains sont partis malheureusement
félix rod numa certains sont partis
d'autres sont encore là ils ont un
certain âge 85 83 ans
certains seront ici pour la deuxième
représentation donc serge claude can
kelly minatchy claude marc coucke donc
ils seront encore là on les a rencontrés
donc mais en même temps nous les
appelons à célébrer cet anniversaire ils
sont encore marqués par cette période
mais c'est aussi l'occasion pour nous
que de dire que notre compagnie
théâtrale qui a 35 ans cette année ci
poursuit son travail de devoir
d'histoire
venez donc écouter une parole qui n'aura
pas été comprise il y à un demi siècle
des éléments de réponses qui sont
apportées par la compagnie le théâtre de
l'air nouveau et qui elle l'espère
donneront des repères à la jeune
génération